[Music]
I'm so happy you did it
so many things to unpack about that
speech of yours this is for you
first things first I mean what it stuck
with me when you said I was so excited
to come to Hollywood and then I wasn't
because they told me I was a minority
thinking about that Journey that stuck
with me because you know you hear the
same things and now you're here has that
sat with you yet we talked about a
little bit on the carpet but has that
sat with you yet that over all the
obstacles and everything that you face
now you're here with this Golden Globe
in your hand
I don't think it's it's hitting me yet I
think that moment of
I really want my name to be said ain't
nothing wrong with it nothing wrong with
it and
it was such a relief that first moment
was relieved I was like they actually
validate and
it's yours
and after that it's like okay I have to
go out there and say something my my
manager David Unger was really sweet he
pushed a piece of paper because they had
worked on things that you should say
these kind of things because you know
this is your moment don't mess it up
when you go up there it's like it's not
about it's not about saying things that
are right but it's saying things that
are from the heart yes and what it
really really meant and it meant the
world
well let me tell y'all so let me look in
this camera go and glow people don't try
to cut off my sister again
I didn't realize I was so naughty I was
like no don't you
and you know I can do it I was like
don't mess with her
with this lady okay
now listen I think you could have
impressed your newest director James
Cameron because uh he probably said oh
she tough I need her to be tough for
Avatar you're going to join the
franchise correct oh yes oh yes okay
starting with three I know that three
has been shot
four is partly shot
everybody's told me that there's new
people joining that I'm going to lose my
mind about
hmm
oh my God stop it can you tell me
anything you just that you can confirm
you're joining the franchise okay okay
yes definitely definitely I've already
put it out there so many times he'll be
so ashamed if he doesn't put me in there
I know you're about to
about oh my God Ariana and Cynthia yeah
they okay first to start off
um John Chu I love John Chu we did crazy
retrusions to the together and before he
went to London I was still working last
year I was still in La filming and he
called me and he says can I meet with
you please please I'm like of course
John you know he's the sweetest so then
he said well I would love if you would
come and join us in in London and I was
like Johnny what are you doing so wicked
and then he then I said okay he's gonna
send me the script please you know
consider it then he goes off and two
days later I'm I get a message from him
and he has recorded a message from
Ariana and Cynthia and him saying hi
Michelle it's imperative
imperative absolutely what was it
imperative that you join us now it was
so sweet from the two girls Michelle you
are popular
but I don't see
well get ready I'm gonna trade
[Music]